my love of movies began at the local
drive-in watching the likes of clint
eastwood and
godzilla our nominees for best
supporting actress all fellow
also fell in love with movies at an
early age
for ya jung yoon it was through the work
of actresses like maggie smith
and directors robert altman and mike lee
for amanda seifert it was the film
version of romeo and juliet
the leo version amanda me too
[Applause]
for maria bacaliva it was all about
marilyn monroe
she'd write out maryland's quote i'm
going to be a great movie star someday
maria welcome
and as a young girl olivia coleman's
family would gather at christmas time
get popcorn and watch the sound of music
and chitty chitty bang bang
and for the great glenn close she was
entranced by classic disney movies
like snow white and old yeller and
apparently paid off she ended up being
cast as cruella deville
these are the nominees for the best
supporting actress
and the oscar goes to jejung yoon
[Applause]
so
mr brad pitt finally
nice to meet you were you where were you
while we were
filming in tulsa
it's very honored to meet you uh
as you know i'm from korea and actually
my name is yao jung yoon and
most of european people call me young
and some of them call me yujung
but tonight you are all forgiven
and well when we
i would usually when i'm living in the
other part of the world i just
watch the television it is an oscar
but event on the television just
watching
[Music]
like a television program for us about
me being here by myself this i cannot
believe
i'm here well just okay
let me put myself together
thank you for the tremendous thanks to
the academy
members that who vote for me
and the next speech okay they usually
say
okay thank you for the
wonderful minority family
stephen isa yeti
and noel ireland we
became a family and most of all
overall liaison without him
i couldn't be here tonight
he was our captain and my director
so thanks to you tremendous thanks to
you
and i'd like to thank to well
she i don't believe in competition
how can i win glenn close up winner of
glenn close
i've been
each available tonight i'm here it's
just i have just a little bit
long i think maybe i'm luckier than you
and also maybe it's a
american hospitality for the korean
actor
i'm not sure but anyway thank you so
much and
i'd like to thanks to my two boys
who made me go out and work so
be loved son all i know
this is the result because mommy works
so hard
and i like to dedicate this award for my
first
director king gyeong who was
very genius director that
i made a movie together with him first
movie i think
he would be very happy if he is still
alive
thank you very much truman's thank you
for
[Applause]
everybody
you